real quick before this video begins I
want to address a few things so some of
you might be thinking man this is a lot
of overkill until some extinct you're
right this is an incredibly intensive
system that I thought but the reason for
it is because I really believe that time
management is one of the most important
things you can do pretty much anything
in your life is achievable if you
leverage your time in the right way and
I just don't think most people including
myself you know for a lot of my life
have a good grip on what we do with our
time and are very intentional with their
time so that's kind of the thesis behind
this whole system and I think for anyone
who's going to embark on this they
should have the proper view to it is
kind of a pain to deal with this
sometimes I think you have to know why
you're doing it and kind of like I said
in the other video as well if you don't
like what I do please PLEASE contain
just make your own systems that's why I
made this smorgasbord system as you can
see this is not some app and the reason
I didn't use an app is because of the
fact that nothing was doing quite what I
wanted it to do and so I had to make my
own system so to some extent I really
believe in kind of doing it yourself so
if you have the evening to do that go
ahead and do that all right let's get
into this video all right guys so we're
going to get into the time management
spreadsheets that I have this is a
follow-up to my last video so this is
for those of you who actually want to
implement this system that I have
alright so basically this is what it
looks like to look like this when you
get it the first thing you're going to
want to do is you're going to want to
think about your day about your life
you're going to think if want to think
about the types of the bucket that you
want to capture so for me these are the
buckets of my life that I want to
capture miscellaneous just as anything
that's kind of productive but you can't
really be captured in some category like
going to the grocery store getting a
haircut something like that waste of
time is just a straight-up waste of time
and these others are pretty
self-explanatory
okay so I track my time in 16-hour days
because I don't
spend a ton of time putting in sleep I
usually sleep from 11 p.m. to 8 a.m.
that's usually when I'm sleeping so I
just consider that that's always that's
always things asleep if you want to
track the whole time you can do that but
I would suggest tracking in 16 hours it
just makes it easier if you want to
change this time you can change it here
just change this first row to like 7:00
a.m. for example and all the rows will
automatically change all right so the
after you change these things over here
these buckets you're going to want to
change them here as well okay don't
change the color because the colors ties
to use a macro so what's a macro it's
just a short little piece of code that
helps things go a little smoother so to
access your macro you need to change a
few things so you're going to go to
options in Excel and then you're going
to go to the customize ribbon page
you're going to click this Developer tab
just going to let you change some things
you don't need to know that much okay so
check this out
so you go to this Developer tab and you
go to visual basic the one thing that
you're going to want to change is this
file path right here
so whenever you get finished with a day
you're gonna press two buttons you're
going to press this button time
management button and it's going to
count up all the colors so like let's go
in a day real quick so let's say when
teachers read some books whatever
miscellaneous this is just a sample day
here okay we worked out blah blah blah
blah she took a nap
okay whatever she lives a little okay so
you finish you finish your day and
you're going to hit this time manager
button it's going to track your day it'd
be the percentages here's the total of
course and then you're going to go
you're gonna press this button before
you do that you're going to want to
change this date to whatever your day is
so it's 26 of April for 26 this is how I
do it
2017 it's just going to name it whatever
whatever is in this first column it's
just going to name that your whole file
that so you're going to press this
button I'm not going to press it but you
can press this button it will change
this name to that and he'll save it in
this file path but it's a specific file
path right here so you're going to go
here you're going to create a folder
that wherever you want to save your
thing I chose time archives so like see
I have this folder right here time
archives you can just click this and
then you can just copy it ctrl C you
just paste it right into here right here
so keep the quotes so that that'll work
out for you and then yeah everything
else should be good to go
don't change the number of buckets just
try to use the same one if you plan
unless you want to write your own macro
which in which case you're fine to do
that okay so that's pretty much the
daily thing I think that's
you press this and you press that okay
alright so now we're going to talk a
little bit about the review system so
okay let's split up okay so here's a
sample review template and this one is a
lot more free you can do a lot more
things with it if you want but I'm going
to try to explain how I use it and you
can kind of do whatever you want so
basically I do two different types of
review systems I do weekly and monthly
you can do them in bigger or smaller
increments if you want so you're
basically going to just for your own
sake right in what time you're capturing
so I'll say like 426 - let's say I'm
doing next week too
what would next weekly what are we gonna
be four or five - so maybe a second so
that's just so you know once you're
actually capturing and so now we're
going to ride in let's say I made a
video about time management and then
that's like you write all your
achievements all the things that you did
that were noteworthy and then you're
going to and like I said you can change
this around whatever fits you you're
going to basically summarize your week
in your own words how you did this is
this is mainly to get you to think about
how you're going to get you to think
about you think you're productive do you
think you want maybe the right like
major - duze for the next week they're
like I said you can change that around
if you want then we're going to do this
this is the most this is the part where
you excerpts pay attention okay so all
that you're going to compile your time
from your past days that you've recorded
in the daily spreadsheet so like let's
go to our time archives real quick sorry
this might take a little bit okay so you
go into our time archives we're going to
open up a bunch of days right so let's
open up just a few just to give you an
idea we'll open up four days but you're
going to open up whatever days your time
period is supposed to be reflecting so
like
okay let's wait for this so 426 -
five - that's the days I would open up
if I were really doing this okay so then
you go to those things and all you're
going to do is you're going to take in
this this thing right here
you know this this right here and you're
going to go back to your view template
you're going to paste that in right here
just like so you're going to go to your
next you're going to close that out I'm
going to go to your next day and you're
going to do the exact same things blah
blah blah you're just going to paste
right down the row okay let's just do
three days for example okay so whatever
so you have these three days you're
going to want to like put them down like
this making sure there's no space
between them I should try where's your
macro like I said if you if you know
anything about VBA you can change this
all to see you but then you're just
going to press compile time sheets and
it's going to summarize it right here
I'm going to tell you how many hours
total
you have percentage of your day that you
spent on each thing and the number of
hours you did
that's pretty much it this will give you
basically the snapshot look of your week
you can graph this if you want to get
like a better more like a better way to
look at your data but anyway that's just
up to you so anyway then you're going to
save it so I'll show you what I do like
month one review nice data or week one a
la week - thanks Sarah
so yeah that's about it and then I just
save it by hand so if you need me more
help with the spreadsheets be sure to
comment let me know or whatnot review
the video if you don't understand
anything
one thing I wanted to mention real quick
guys is let's say that you did not fill
in something for your day this happens
to me occasionally where I'll just
forget from doing something else I'm
busy you know what have you what do you
do okay you want to go back in don't
give yourself a hard time just fill in
generally what you did just ballpark it
but the point is is to get is to try not
to miss any day so even if you have to
just estimate and I think that will do
you really well so that's just something
practical that I've had to come to grips
with and sometimes you just you forget
you're doing something else
you just have to estimate it it's okay
the point is build up over time just
this grand view of what your time is
looking like and on the grand scheme of
things that still will be pretty
accurate
so yeah anyway okay guys thanks for
watching